[Music]
hi chuck i got another explainer for you
oh well i'm here to get it
yeah yeah there's no end of these i
don't think that's well no
i will run out at one point my brain
will be empty and i'll just be this this
vessel right that i used to have stuff
in it a hollow cell
a hollow shell it's all online at that
point
i'll need to do some one of these one of
these uh consciousness uploads
to get my brain back from everything i
put on online
but i i have to address
something that i think we've seen in the
news
you know every six months goes by and
then you see a headline oh uh
astrophysicists have to rethink the big
bang or big bang
debunked or or did you did you see any
of these at any time oh my god but well
recently the james webb space telescope
supposedly
the headline is
um did the james wells webb's telescope
um make scientists think the rig the big
bang or has the james webb telescope
debunked the big bang yeah it makes
excellent clickbait yeah there it is
it's it's click bait headlines so let me
just explain a few things that's going
on here okay
uh on the frontier of scientific
research
it is a bloody place
all right ideas are slayed two
scientists enter
one scientist leaves
it's the octagon
welcome to science dome
[Laughter]
on the frontier ideas are contested
daily right
and
most ideas turn out to be wrong
all right so
so what you are as a scientist working
on the frontier
you're in this idea factory that's what
you are
and the successful idea is not the one
that's argued most strenuously or argued
by the most articulate that's called
politics it's called politics exactly
exactly
uh it's not it has nothing to do with
either of those it has to do with
evidence
all right which idea is supported by
evidence so typically what happens is
you can test your ideas and here's where
you have to be convincing you have to
say i i think my idea is better than
your idea and here's a way to test it
right
so i have an idea so if you don't like
me
the way you show it is you design an
experiment to show them wrong
okay well that's some cutthroat nasty
stuff that's some cut
this is some nasty all right that's some
real housewives stuff
real housewives
let me tell you something phaedra your
hypothesis
is trash
[Laughter]
so scientists can test their ideas so
you
uh you don't like me and you're gonna
show me that i'm wrong and so you go
home and you invent an experiment
you invent an experiment to test my idea
with the objective of showing that i'm
wrong and it turns out hey wait a minute
i'm getting what the dude says right you
got to publish that and then someone
else performs
performs another kind of experiment
aimed at testing the same hypothesis
and they get kind of the same result and
then someone from a different country
with a different wall current
240 volts maybe and they plug their
stuff in and they're getting the same
result
when you have repeated experiments
verifying an idea
we have a new objective truth
that has emerged in those sciences
and what i'm telling you
is that
the big bang
theory
by the way if you type that into google
you get the tv show just i'm my personal
jury is still out on whether that's a
good or bad thing um you know it doesn't
mean like science is so popular it's a
tv show that's the first thing you hit
because you got to get through that then
there's the big bang is a k-pop group
you got to get through that
then you get to the origin of the
universe okay in the google search just
thought i'd point that out it's good to
know that we google in order of
importance
[Laughter]
there it is
just saying wow all right so
so here's the point
the tenets of the big bang that the
universe started out small
hot
dense
uh where matter and energy were a
primordial soup
where the forces of nature had merged
all of that is thoroughly supported by
observations of this universe
thoroughly supported
okay now there are some things that well
did this really cause that or might it
be something that we don't know about
yet
and who ordered up the dark matter we
don't know where that came from and
where's this expansion
we don't know where that came from but
we can describe it and we can measure it
here's the point
if tomorrow you have a new idea about
how the universe works
it's going to enclose everything we've
been talking about up to that moment
that has been experimentally and
observationally verified
you can close it in something deeper
okay you can say oh and i have an idea
our universe is just one in a multiverse
fine okay but our universe would have
started with a big bang okay
and our universe would have expanded
from a dense hot cool state and it's
been cooling ever since
that's observed and that's real and
that's not going away
that's my point so so what you have are
journalists trying to make click bait
and if there's some little thing in the
early universe that is still on the
frontier still being contested in the
octagon in this in the in the fight dome
and and some new idea is emerging over
another idea
oh big bang is in trouble so i just go
back to the drawing but big man is not
in trouble right
i'm just saying it's not in trouble it
is a whole
thing that could conceivably fit in a
deeper bigger idea
right but it's not going to be swapped
out tomorrow we're not going to find out
tomorrow gee
uh
the early universe was cold instead of
hot that's not going to happen
that's not how science works
so if you're going to come up with
something new
you're not coming up with
something that will change the old
all you have to the all that has been
experimentally verified right if you're
going to come up with something new
about the earth and the sun it's not
going to be well
it's really earth is stationary and the
sun moves around the earth and the sun
is cold and earth is hot and earth is
what's illuminating the moon that is not
going to happen right right okay you
can't just pull an idea out of your
orifice and ignore experimental
verification of what's going on right so
you might you might come up with the big
fang but you're not changing the big
bang
what what's the best c plus on that one
it's what came before the big bang we
call it the big thing the big thing
okay that's a b plus if that's
what's your thing yeah that's before the
big bang
[Laughter]
so
and and by the way the when we think of
einsteinian physics
so it's relativity
which
completely
uh usurped newtonian gravity and
newtonian motion all right what we call
clot the error of classical physics
which led right up to the late 1800s
newton's ideas reigns supreme
all right and
he told you what gravity did what motion
did and acceleration in a pre-existing
space and it was working okay
it was working and then people said well
wait a minute
uh the orbit of mercury is not really
following newton's laws
and we said oh we got this we know we
got this there's a there's another
planet you can't see that's tugging on
it we even had a name for that planet it
was called vulcan okay
we a hypothetical planet tugging on
mercury so that we didn't have to throw
out newton's laws all right so that was
invoked just out of do we just pull that
out of our ass right said there it is
we'll find it one day
einstein comes along with a special
theory of relativity and then his
general theory of relativity and what we
find is that at high gravity like near
the sun
and at high speeds
at high gravity and high speeds
newton's laws completely fail you cannot
use them at all
so do we say did we throw away newton no
we didn't you know why
because if you take einstein's equations
and plug in
low speeds and low gravity
they become newton's equations
yes so einstein basically
enclosed newton's
ideas as a special low-speed low-gravity
case of a much larger deeper
understanding of the universe fantastic
it's it is it is beautiful it is and so
so and by the way newton's uh newton's
uh gravity and newton's motion went just
fine for the apollo project right we got
to the moon and back without any
einstein relativity at all okay so it's
only if you really uh
um up the stakes in
your gravity there's no wonder way to
understand black holes really with or
even the big bang itself with just
newtonian physics point is
new physics
does not undo experimentally verified
physics that's the whole point of
experimental verification that's all
look at that and so the big bang is just
fine you want to do something else with
it take it body and soul and stick it in
some other theory you have but you can't
undo what the experiments and
observations have shown
and that
is an explainer for you there you go wow
that is good take that big
big bang deniers take that
um so that's that's an explainer from
the octagon
[Laughter]
from the scientist fight club there it
is
science fight club i love it all right
so we got to end it there chuck always
good to have you always a pleasure all
right
neil degrasse tyson here for star trek
[Music]
you